Community Pride on Las Vegas now is
sponsored by Findlay automotive group
Southwest Medical part of Optum care
Silver State Schools Credit Union and NV
Energy
Optum the sponsors of this segment are
taking purple strides for pancreatic
cancer I spoke to a doctor to learn how
you can do that too
Dr gollard welcome back
thank you it's great to be here good to
see you again I know you have some very
important information to share on
pancreatic cancer so let's get started
what should we know
well I think we should all know that
it's a very very common cancer many many
Americans are afflicted with it every
year and there are risk factors family
history race ethnicity smoking diabetes
obesity just uh getting older all these
things can increase your risk of getting
pancreatic cancer now one of the
problems with diagnosing pancreatic
cancer early is that it presents in a
non-specific fashion uh sometimes people
can have unexplained weight loss
frequently pain is in the mid to lower
back or abdomen digestive problems and
then
um
as time goes by and the cancer becomes
more advanced the skin can turn yellow
as uh obstruction in the bile tract
curves also abdominal bloating and a
change in stool and even the onset of
diabetes mellitus can signal the onset
of pancreatic cancer so there's a lot of
things that can signal the need for
screening and diagnostic testing to be
done
absolutely and thank you for that that's
really important for people to know even
family members in case they're seeing
changes in their in their loved ones how
can the community support the education
of pancreatic cancer and you know
raising funds for efforts to to cure it
uh supporting education and the
fundraising efforts of pan can that's
the pancreatic cancer Action Network in
events like purple stride Las Vegas this
is a really great place to make
donations uh learn more about the
disease and also spread the word often
care Cancer Care uh we're the premier
sponsor and we believe in the power of
this event to unite people and raise
awareness in Las Vegas and really make a
difference
specifically purple stride Las Vegas
2023 uh this is the number one way funds
are raised to end pancreatic cancer and
that's on Saturday April 29th at UNLV in
the Valerie Peta Plaza uh what I would
recommend doing is walking around the
event grabbing a snack riding on the
tribute wall uh taking pictures with
family and friends in the photo area and
really be inspired uh during the opening
ceremony to set off on this ultimate
walk to end pancreatic cancer
what you'll learn is that pancreatic
cancer is not a death sense there are
many people that are diagnosed with
pancreatic cancer and are doing well
even years later and some are even going
to be curing so that's really really
important now to register donate please
visit the website
purplestride.org forward slash Las Vegas
thank you to Optum for being one of our
Community Pride Partners we'll be right
back online